pegi 18
[Musique]
au volet volley ball je vais encore
devoir te démonter
et dave quelque chose d'interdît en
existe la mandibule fait vingt cinq
centimètres canine maxillaire
spectaculairement alger
dead
pour toi utile
bon bah c'était sympa non
[Musique]
c'est à toi mec
faites de beaux rêves savez ce que ça me
rappelle cette fois dans l'himalaya
internet
[Musique]
vous savez qui te pousse tué quand ils
veulent connard
[Musique]
apportez-nous leur sang pourquoi est ce
qu'on a toujours des problèmes
bienvenue chercheurs de vérité ici
goodyear course vraiment j'aime le
terrain à red bull massachusetts
derrière moi nous apercevons des signes
clairs d'activité secteurs de la
population locale participe je sers ta
vidéo valeur reculait le monde doit
savoir ce qui s'est passé avec moi
sur le toit il est là tu gères jacob
était rien
très vite c'est maintenant ou jamais
[Musique]
elle est ou l'autre elle est passée
victoire
laissons [ __ ] beulin
je passe à jacob black est un beau move
est un petit gars bordel bva dorée celle
là
j'espère que tu as un plan jacob ouais
il est juste
tous pas nouveau l'immunité
tiré du rémois rien n'arrêtera je crois
qu'hier du vampire lada vraiment ça a
quel go soit spécifique un goût de sang
et de morts et de fraises
le soleil se lève il faut qu'on bosse il
faut qu'on bouge si tu le dis
rimbaud elle est pas mal vous pensez les
choses redeviendront normales un jour tu
voudrais que ça redevienne normale pas
si je dois encore rembourser mon prêt
étudiant
[Musique]